but there oh a cat a call coming in from
simon rex a nap right now dirt nice he's
in the hospital you wanna say - Oh what
happened - I don't really want to see ya
all right no servants in hospitals not
good thing good wealthy dirt you want to
be on King in this thing or no yeah this
is heaven dude unfortunately when you
unfortunately yeah you got into the kind
of rough heaven it's just me and Brendan
is what it looks like laughing gasps
relaxing you URI man oh damn how'd that
happen
Planned Parenthood it's like snow white
kind of like when she bites that Apple
[Music]
well and that is actually probably a
warning that a lot of our got that a lot
of because we have a lot of young males
out there who I'm sure struggling in the
nut if you got whiteheads on your nuts
man be careful out there
you got a happy on your nuts how would
you do a different Simon it would you do
anything different or what you just are
going straight to the hospital earlier
what would you train brother man welcome
to heaven well welcome to heaven man we
all love you and we hope that you feel
better fast brother take care of that
sack row you know there's a lot of great
people up here dude
Petros is up here yeah they're not
telling anybody but yeah surprise
Michael Jackson's up here as well my man
Spacey yeah there's definitely Spacey
could be here too so but we love you man
I hope you feel better soon man and I'll
hit you up later
your doctor survived the real one today
upon you to bestow yourself upon such
ridiculous circumstances I'll leave it
at that later bro
dang those nuts dude man hope ease hope
he makes it out I mean yeah that's crazy
something's in his nuts anyone to get it
it sounds like yeah anything growing
hair on your nuts that's I've never
heard of that well how do you I guess
your nuts are actually because there's
something outside of my nuts like a skin
bag yours too right yeah like a bat wing
yeah just like a coin with like a thing
for coins or something yeah like a
leather pouch cuz nobody has just two
nuts hanging there with nothing around
him right no and then there's like a few
fickle hairs on a banana has hairy nut
Oh a lot of people do not hairy nuts
like real beard where you don't think he
probably has a beard on his nuts also
look at deira Clark and junior do you
don't think dear Perry no no bro that's
so true yeah I can't even imagine man
neither can you draw a picture of it if
you gave me two hours and about sixty
markers I couldn't even draw I don't
have the mind for it yeah I just I came
in imagine that it always clean-shaved
in the pornos man what why are you
looking at him in the pornos man you got
a G up brother
I am Jesus it's ladies owners gia no I
look at the ladies only brother well
sometimes you get that dick in your face
you can't do anything about it
yeah you can here's what I do bro
fast-forward just like that now that you
missed the movie dude huh
then you miss the movie yeah you know
what's going on right you're right
yes enjoy yeah you're right
back off my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
you